Action movies are known for placing the hero
in nail biting life or death situations where
there’s danger at every turn.
Sometimes the sequences are so risky, the
filmmakers will enlist the help of a stunt
double so their lead stays safe.
But then there are the real daredevils in
Hollywood who prefer to do as much as possible
themselves to ensure maximum authenticity.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Actors Who Refuse
to Use Stunt Doubles.
Harrison Ford
A veteran of several action movies, Ford is
never afraid to get his hands dirty.
Throughout filming of the Indiana Jones series,
the actor enjoyed the physical nature of the
character and trained hard so he could do
his own stunts.
He liked it so much, stuntman Vic Armstrong
told Ford that if he kept it up, Armstrong
would be out of a job.
Ford hasn’t backed away from stunt work
in his older years.
According to J.J. Abrams, Ford was one of
the most active members of the Force Awakens
cast, even after breaking his leg.
Tom Cruise
One of the leading action stars of this generation,
Tom Cruise ups the ante every time he makes
a film.
His feats in the Mission: Impossible franchise
are perhaps his most famous.
During the now iconic Burj Khalifa scene in
Ghost Protocol, Cruise is the one scaling
the skyscraper.
For its sequel, the actor actually hung on
to a real plane taking off, giving his fans
a treat they’ll never forget.
With the M:I films now better than ever, there’s
no telling what Cruise will do next or how
far he’ll go.
The one thing we do know is that it’ll always
be the real deal.
Keanu Reeves
Rising to fame in the 1990s, Reeves has put
together an impressive action movie résumé.
Starting with Speed in 1994, the actor has
been keen to do his own stunts.
He reportedly did 90 percent of the stunts
for Speed, and performed many of the fight
scenes and wirework in the Matrix trilogy.
Later on in his career, Reeves wowed moviegoers
with the jaw-dropping sequences in John Wick,
cementing his status as one of the go-to leads
for the genre.
Moviegoers can’t wait for John Wick’s
sequel, and Reeves’ dedication to his craft
is a big reason why.
Angelina Jolie
Jolie’s trainer Simon Crane claims that
the actress does 99 percent of her own stunts
over the course of her career, which includes
several forays into action flicks.
Her most impressive credit is the thriller
Salt, in which Jolie did not use a stunt double
at all.
When viewers see the character diving through
doors or walking on a narrow ledge, it’s
actually Jolie.
She also performed stunts while filming Disney’s
Maleficent, where one action sequence required
her to be suspended in the air before getting
flung into the air.
Jolie’s still going strong after all these
years, so hopefully she keeps it up.
Daniel Craig
Playing James Bond is no easy task, and Daniel
Craig was more than up for the challenge.
The actor established himself as one of the
toughest and roughest 007s yet.
Feeling that it was important to do his own
stunts, Craig made sure he was in top physical
condition so he was fit to do the work himself.
He does leave some of the more massive and
dangerous stunts for the professionals, but
Craig has done as much as he can, giving a
personal stamp on his take on the spy.
After four of these films, it’s no wonder
he sounds like he’s ready to move on.
He needs a vacation.
Matt Damon
An unlikely action star, Matt Damon helped
redefine the genre in the 2000s with the acclaimed
Bourne trilogy, and he played the part to
perfection.
In the films, Damon was up for doing some
of the driving himself, taking part in the
series’ exciting car chases.
He also did a few scenes underwater, which
made him particularly nervous.
Outside of his big franchise, Damon has also
handled stunts in films like Saving Private
Ryan and Courage Under Fire.
With a new Bourne film just around the corner,
who knows what Damon will do next?
Jason Statham
Making his career out of starring in action
films, Jason Statham enjoys the adrenaline
rush from doing his own stunts.
His filmography is chock full of great examples,
making it difficult to choose just one as
his biggest highlight.
Statham has proven himself as a master of
stunt driving, but he feels as if he’s dug
himself into a hole.
He’s so great and doing stunts, his fans
expect something bigger and greater each time
out, forcing Statham to test his limits and
defy death on numerous occasions.
But it’s something he loves and he keeps
on delivering, so we’re not complaining.
Arnold Schwarzenegger
Partially because filmmakers could rarely
find a stunt double that matched the action
legend’s unique build, Arnold did many of
his own stunts in his films.
It’s no surprise that the actor was up for
the task, since he was always in peak physical
condition as a bodybuilder.
His ability as a stuntman was what launched
him into Hollywood in the first place, and
Schwarzenegger has never looked back.
He refused to use a stunt double during The
Last Stand because he wanted everything to
feel as real as possible.
Even as an aging icon, he’s still got it.
Sylvester Stallone
Sly broke out as a dramatic actor in Rocky,
but made a name for himself as an action star
as his career progressed.
Stallone showed supreme dedication in his
films, and was always willing to sacrifice
his body.
During Rocky IV, he was sent to intensive
care after being punched by Dolph Lundgren
and broke his neck while filming the first
Expendables movie.
As great as it was to see him return to his
roots in Creed, we hope Stallone’s action
days aren’t past him yet.
There’s something to admire in his ability
to take the hits and keep pushing forward.
Cameron Diaz
Not the first name that comes to mind when
thinking of dangerous stunts, Diaz has showcased
her mettle in more ways than one.
Acting opposite Tom Cruise in Knight and Day,
Diaz performed many of the action sequences
herself, including the stunt driving.
She suffered a few cuts and bruises along
the way, but it helped sell her character
and make the scenes seem real.
And besides, Knight and Day wasn’t her first
go-around with the genre; Diaz starred in
two Charlie’s Angels films to cut her teeth
as an action star in the making.
Those are our picks for Hollywood stars that
refuse to get a stunt double.
Are there any we missed?
Which death-defying actors are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!